It's been a week for looking at pictures, of the bombings in Boston, of course, the aftermath, the FBI suspects, everything that's happened since. By Wednesday, a few people in our office were going onto Reddit, the online discussion board, to read the conversation where amateurs were scouring through those crowd photos of hundreds of faces, searching for anybody who might be a bomber. Zach Barnett was one of those amateurs.
这周我们一直在看照片，当然，主要是关于波士顿爆炸案及其后果、联邦调查局怀疑的对象，以及之后发生的一切。到周三时，我们办公室里有几个人开始上Reddit在线讨论版，阅读上面的对话，业余爱好者们正在仔细搜寻数百张现场人群的照片，寻找任何可能是炸弹客的人。扎克·巴内特就是这些业余爱好者之一。
And he was a skeptic. He started Tuesday morning. When posters started chattering about a guy in the crowd that they nicknamed Music Man, a guy who was wearing headphones, a black jacket with a huge black backpack-- it was the huge backpack that made him suspicious-- Zach was the person who alerted everyone.
他是个怀疑论者。他从周二早上就开始了。当网友们开始议论人群中一个被他们昵称为“音乐人”的家伙时——一个戴着耳机，穿着黑色夹克，背着巨大黑色背包的家伙——正是那个巨大的背包让他显得很可疑——扎克就是那个提醒大家的人。
There was an image after the bombing had taken place with tons of ambulances on the scene. And there was what seemed to be Music Man with his backpack. And so this seemed to suggest that he was not responsible.
在爆炸发生后，有一张照片里现场有很多救护车。而那个“音乐人”背着他的背包也在那里。这似乎暗示他并不是肇事者。
Because if he has the backpack after the blast, obviously, it's not his backpack that caused the blast.
因为如果他在爆炸后还有那个背包，显然，炸弹不可能是由他的背包引起的。
Right. Right.
没错。对。
After this display of level headedness, Zach, who is a college student, was asked to be one of the moderators of the discussion on Reddit. There's been some criticism of Reddit for going through Boston Marathon photos looking for suspects. The Atlantic called it vigilantism and made it seem like these were crazed nerds on a delusional CSI witch hunt. And you definitely can find quotes that make it seem that way.
在展示了这种冷静的判断力之后，身为大学生的扎克被邀请成为Reddit讨论版的版主之一。Reddit因搜寻波士顿马拉松照片以寻找嫌疑人而受到了一些批评。《大西洋月刊》称这是一种私刑行为，把它描述成一群疯狂的极客在搞妄想式的CSI式搜捕。你确实可以找到一些让情况看起来像那样的引语。
But if you read the full discussions, you'll see how careful people are trying to be, very aware of the dangers of accusing an innocent person of being a bomber. It's a big part of the discussion. When somebody posts the Facebook page of one potential suspect, people declared, this has gone too far.
但如果你阅读完整的讨论，你会发现人们是多么谨慎，非常清楚指控无辜者是炸弹客的危险。这是讨论中很大的一部分。当有人发布了一名潜在嫌疑人的Facebook页面时，人们宣告：这太过分了。
The post is deleted. The poster's banned. And Zach was far from the only skeptic. Take, for example, the discussion of a pair of guys they called the Backpack Brothers because one of them had a big, heavy looking black backpack.
帖子被删除了。发帖者被封禁了。扎克远不是唯一的怀疑论者。比如，讨论那一对被他们称为“背包兄弟”的人，因为其中一人背着一个看起来又大又沉的黑色背包。
And he was wearing a white hat with some glasses on top of the hat. And then there was another man in blue track suit and running shoes, which isn't exactly out of place at a marathon.
他戴着一顶白色帽子，帽子上面架着一副眼镜。还有另一个穿着蓝色运动服和跑鞋的男人，这在马拉松赛上并不显得格格不入。
And he has a duffel bag, right?
他背着一个行李袋，对吧？
Yeah. He had a duffel bag over his shoulder.
是的。他肩上背着一个行李袋。
There were a couple things about the Backpack Brothers photos that made Zach feel like of all the pictures, these had the greatest likelihood to be real suspects. Somebody linked to this ingenious photo which superimposed the shot of the Backpack Brothers on the sidewalk before the explosion with a picture of the same stretch of sidewalk after the bombs went off, with a big red circle drawn at the spot where the bombs supposedly had blown up. And damned if it wasn't exactly next to where those two guys had been standing. And even more damning were other photos taken still before the blast.
关于“背包兄弟”的照片有几件事让扎克觉得，在所有的照片中，这些照片最有可能拍到了真正的嫌疑人。有人链接了一张很有创意的照片，它将爆炸前人行道上的“背包兄弟”与炸弹爆炸后同一路段的照片叠加在一起，并在据称炸弹爆炸的地点画了一个大红圈。该死，它正好就在那两个人站立位置的旁边。而更具决定性的是在爆炸前拍摄的其他照片。
Where one of them definitely didn't have his bag. The person with the white hat did not have his bag with him. And the other one, you couldn't really tell if he did or didn't.
其中一个人确定没带他的包。戴白帽子的那个人身上没有他的包。另一个人，你无法确定他有没有。
And so the speculation is they had bags before the blast. And then later, still before the blast, they had left their bags somewhere.
所以推测是他们在爆炸前带着包。然后后来，在爆炸前，他们把包留在了某个地方。
Exactly. And based on the time of when the images were taken, which you could see the marathon clock in the photo, it did line up with roughly when people thought that the bags had been dropped. And so this led people to really be suspicious of these two.
没错。根据拍摄图像的时间（照片里可以看到马拉松计时钟），这与人们认为包被丢弃的时间大致吻合。因此，这让人们真正怀疑起这两个人。
But by Wednesday, people at Reddit were discussing the details that would make you less suspicious of these two. Like, for example, the duffel bag was blue. Authorities never mentioned a bomb in a blue bag. Or, most important, except for the white cap, these two guys did not match the description of the suspects that authorities started to circulate by Wednesday afternoon. So by the end of the day Wednesday, most posters on Reddit, including Zach, seemed to be moving away from the Backpack Brothers as possible bombers.
但到了周三，Reddit上的人们开始讨论那些会让你对这两个人减少怀疑的细节。例如，行李袋是蓝色的。当局从未提到炸弹装在蓝色袋子里。或者最重要的一点是，除了白色帽子，这两个人与当局在周三下午开始发布描述的嫌疑人特征并不相符。所以到周三结束时，Reddit上的大多数发帖者，包括扎克，似乎都在排除“背包兄弟”作为潜在炸弹客的可能性。
Of course, this wasn't true everywhere. On Thursday morning, the New York Post blasted a photo of the Backpack Brothers across its front page-- it's the entire front page-- with a screaming headline, "Bag Men. Feds seek these two pictured at Boston Marathon." Somehow, the Post didn't notice that these two men do not match the description of the suspects that was circulating by then.
当然，这并非在所有地方都如此。周四早上，《纽约邮报》在其头版刊登了一张巨大的“背包兄弟”照片——那是整个头版——并配上了刺眼的标题：“袋子男人。联邦调查局搜寻这两名在波士顿马拉松赛中被拍到的人。”不知何故，《纽约邮报》没有注意到这两个人与当时流传的嫌疑人特征不符。
By Thursday afternoon, authorities had publicly declared that these two men were not suspects. Photos of the real suspects were released. The Backpack Brothers turned out to be a high school sophomore, who was very surprised at all this attention, and his friend. And on Thursday when I talked to Zach about all the various photos, he was super careful not to jump to any conclusions, which, of course, is difficult.
到周四下午，当局公开宣布这两个人不是嫌疑人。真正的嫌疑人照片被发布了。“背包兄弟”原来是一名对这种关注感到非常惊讶的高中二年级学生，以及他的朋友。周四，当我与扎克谈论所有这些照片时，他非常谨慎，不急于得出任何结论，这当然很难。
It just is so hard to look at these pictures without imposing a story on it.
看这些照片时，不把一个故事强加给它们实在太难了。
Yeah, exactly. You just can't help but read the photograph, not just see it for what it is but to read a story on to it.
是啊，完全正确。你忍不住要去解读照片，不仅仅是看它本来的样子，而是要从中读出一个故事。
Like here at our office this week, it was hard for all of us to not feel like, oh, look, look, it's him. It must be him. This must be the guy. And were you having feelings like that, too?
就像这周在我们办公室，我们所有人都很难不产生那种感觉：噢，看，看，就是他。一定是他。这一定是那个人。你也有过这种感觉吗？
Oh, yeah. You can't help it. When people are posting all these images, and there's this person circled, and there's an arrow drawn from this person to this person saying, oh, these two are working together. And the danger is not even just that people are going to speculate and jump to conclusions that are unwarranted, but really what's going to happen when you jump to unwarranted conclusions. Who's going to be affected?
噢，当然。你忍不住的。当人们发布所有这些图片，有人把这个人圈出来，还有一条箭头从这个人指向那个人说，“噢，这两个人是一伙的”。危险不仅在于人们会猜测并得出毫无根据的结论，而在于当你得出毫无根据的结论时，真正会发生什么。谁会受到影响？
A picture is what you think it means. It is not self-evident. And today on our radio show, we have two stories where there are pictures. And in each of them, whether you think the pictures are worrisome and troubling depends on what you believe about the story of how they were made. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Two mysteries will unfold. Stay with us.
照片是你认为它意味着什么。它并非不言自明。今天在我们的电台节目中，有两个关于照片的故事。在每个故事中，无论你认为这些照片是令人担忧还是困扰，都取决于你如何相信这些照片是如何产生的。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。两个谜团即将展开。请继续收听。
Act One, Photo Op. It's no surprise that people disagree about how to interpret the photos and videos in this first story, because the photos and videos were shot in a part of the world where people disagree about how to interpret so, so many things. Nancy Updike tells the story.
第一幕，拍照机会。人们在这个故事中对如何解读照片和视频产生分歧并不奇怪，因为这些照片和视频是在世界上一个人们对如何解读太多事情都存在分歧的地方拍摄的。南希·厄普代克讲述了这个故事。
I saw a video a while back that caught my attention. It's short, a shaky handheld video. And it shows an interaction between Israeli soldiers and a Palestinian family where there is no violence, no yelling, no confrontation. In the video, five Israeli soldiers show up at the house of a Palestinian family in a village named Nabi Saleh.
前一阵子我看到一段吸引了我注意的视频。它很短，是一段晃动的手持视频。它显示了以色列士兵和一个巴勒斯坦家庭之间的互动，没有暴力，没有叫喊，没有对抗。视频中，五名以色列士兵出现在纳比萨利赫村一个巴勒斯坦家庭的房门前。
It's around 1:00 in the morning. The father answers the door, and he starts to film what's happening. And the soldiers let him film. The soldier in charge asks the man in Hebrew if there are any children in the house and how many.
大约是凌晨1点。父亲开了门，开始拍摄正在发生的事情。士兵们让他拍。负责的士兵用希伯来语问那个男人家里有没有孩子，有多少个。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
The man's got four children, three of whom are here at the house now. The little girl is at her grandfather's. How many sons, the soldier asks. Three.
这个男人有四个孩子，其中三个现在在家里。小女孩在她祖父家。士兵问有多少个儿子。三个。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
The soldier asks to see the two oldest boys, 15 years old and almost 12 years old. The man says they're asleep. And the soldier asks him to wake them up, please.
士兵要求见两个最大的男孩，一个15岁，一个快12岁。男人说他们在睡觉。士兵请他叫醒他们。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
The man goes into the next room and calls his kids' names a couple of times. Again, it's around 1:00 in the morning. The kids lift up their heads, blink in the light, and slowly get out of bed.
男人走进隔壁房间，叫了几声孩子们的名字。再次重申，那时大约凌晨1点。孩子们抬起头，在灯光下眨眼，缓慢地起床。
They stand next to each other in the doorway of their room looking at the soldiers, who are in full gear, helmets, guns. The younger boy has dark blond hair, and his face is a little puffy with sleep. When the soldier in command says hello, he says his name, Muhammad.
他们站在房间门口并排站着，看着那些全副武装、戴着头盔、拿着枪的士兵。较小的男孩有一头深金色的头发，因为睡眠而脸部显得有点浮肿。当指挥的士兵打招呼时，他说出了自己的名字：穆罕默德。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
(SUBJECT) MUHAMMAD TAMIMI Muhammad.
（受访者）穆罕默德·塔米米：穆罕默德。
The soldiers write down the boys' names and ID numbers. And then they take a photo of each kid. They've already taken a photo of the father.
士兵记下了男孩们的名字和身份证号。然后给每个孩子拍了张照。他们已经给那个父亲拍过照了。
During the whole process, no one offers or asks for a warrant, a charge, an explanation. As the soldiers leave, the one in command glances at another door in the building and says, any more children? The father says no.
在整个过程中，没有人提供或要求出示搜查令、指控或解释。当士兵们离开时，指挥官瞥了一眼楼里的另一扇门说：“还有其他孩子吗？”父亲说没有。
The only question the father asks is, can he go with the soldiers and keep filming while they go to the next house? They say no at first. And he says, why not? So they let him.
父亲问的唯一一个问题是：他能跟着士兵们去下一家房子继续拍摄吗？他们起初说不行。他说，为什么不行？于是他们同意了。
I watch the unedited video he made that night, and I counted 12 more houses that the soldiers went to, waking up kids and photographing them. The undrama of this video is mesmerizing, the routineness, like watching a series of traffic stops. I've been coming to the West Bank reporting on and off for 15 years.
我看了他那天晚上拍摄的未经剪辑的视频，我数了一下，士兵们又去了12家房子，叫醒孩子们并给他们拍照。这段视频中那种平淡无奇令人着迷，那份惯例，就像观看一系列交通检查。我作为记者断断续续来西岸报道已经15年了。
And I've been here when the routine was suicide bombings in Israel and in the West Bank, tanks and daily shootings. But it hasn't been like that for a long time. And the army taking photos of kids at night is something I'd never seen before.
我也曾经历过在以色列和西岸发生自杀式炸弹袭击、坦克和日常枪击的时期。但那种情况已经很久没有发生了。而军队在晚上给孩子拍照是我以前从未见过的事情。
Watching the video, I felt like it was a window into this moment in the West Bank, this period of quasi-stability. Israel went into the West Bank 46 years ago. What does it take to control so many people so effectively for so long?
观看这段视频时，我觉得它是了解西岸此刻、这个准稳定时期的一个窗口。以色列在46年前进入西岸。要如此有效地长期控制这么多人需要什么？
And I know that lots of Americans feel like they have no right to ask questions about what Israel does, because they're not there, and they don't know what it's like to live with the dangers Israelis live with. But what Americans never seem to realize is how much Israelis ask questions, including about this video of soldiers photographing kids. The video aired on Israel's Channel 10 and also made the rounds on Israeli Twitter feeds and Facebook pages.
我知道许多美国人觉得他们没有权利质疑以色列的做法，因为他们不在那里，也不知道像以色列人那样生活在危险中是什么感觉。但美国人似乎从未意识到以色列人有多少质疑声，包括关于这段士兵给孩子拍照的视频。这段视频在以色列第10频道播出，也在以色列的推特和Facebook页面上流传。
And plenty of people who saw the video said, well, the army's got to do what the army's got to do. But others were disturbed. They had questions.
很多人看到视频后说：军队必须做军队该做的事。但其他人感到不安。他们有疑问。
And why shouldn't they? It's their sons and daughters who are in the West Bank or wherever else right after high school for years of mandatory military service. So I've got a question. What are these nighttime photos? The photos at night aren't new. It's a tactic that comes and goes, part of something the Israeli military calls mapping.
为什么他们不该有疑问呢？在高中毕业后，他们的儿子和女儿会被派往西岸或其他任何地方进行多年的强制军事服役。所以，我有一个问题。这些夜间照片是什么？夜间拍照并不新鲜。这是一种时有时无的战术，是以色列军队称之为“绘图”的一部分。
This is mapping. In the middle of the night, the guy is in his pajamas.
这就是绘图。在半夜，这个家伙穿着睡衣。
Yehuda Shaul did his army service during the Second Intifada years ago. But he did a lot of mapping. And he's talked to a lot of other soldiers about it. He's showing me a snapshot taken by a soldier in 2008 in the West Bank city of Nablus. And the photo shows an older Palestinian man, who seems to be in his pajamas, sitting at a table in his house across from an Israeli soldier who's writing something down on a piece of paper.
耶胡达·沙尔几年前在第二次起义期间服过兵役。但他做过很多绘图。他也和其他士兵谈论过这件事。他给我看了一张士兵2008年在西岸城市纳布卢斯拍摄的快照。照片显示一名似乎穿着睡衣的年长巴勒斯坦人，坐在自家桌子旁，对面是一名以色列士兵，正在一张纸上写着什么。
Yeah, basically, the ID numbers of the people who live, the names, drawing who works where, cell phones, all the kind of stuff that you collect in mapping.
是的，基本上是记录居住者的身份证号、姓名，绘制谁在哪里工作、手机号码，以及你在绘图过程中收集的所有这类东西。
Mapping is actually a general term that can mean a lot of different things-- photographs, diagrams of the layout of a house, where the windows and balconies are, what doors lead to which streets. Mapping's not violent, and months can go by without any mapping.
绘图实际上是一个通用术语，可以指很多不同的事情——照片、房屋布局图、窗户和阳台在哪里，哪些门通往哪些街道。绘图并不暴力，几个月没做绘图也是可能的。
So it's not something that usually makes the news. It's just one more part of the overall routine in the West Bank these days. The mapping and nighttime photos started in Nabi Saleh, the village from the video you heard, a few months after the villagers began doing a weekly protest march, according to residents.
所以这通常不是新闻。这只是当今西岸整体惯例的又一部分。据居民称，绘图和夜间拍照在纳比萨利赫村（你听到的视频中的村庄）开始，是在村民们开始举行每周抗议游行几个月后。
These protests are also part of the routine in the West Bank. They happen every Friday. They happen in lots of villages. They've been happening in different villages for years. And there's practically a script.
这些抗议也是西岸惯例的一部分。它们每周五发生。它们发生在许多村庄。它们在不同的村庄已经持续多年了。而且几乎有一个脚本。
In Nabi Saleh, the day I was there, there was a march, chanting. The villagers faced off against some soldiers. And after an hour or so of this, a lot of the adults left.
在纳比萨利赫，我在的那天，有一场游行，高喊着口号。村民们与一些士兵对峙。大约一小时后，许多成年人离开了。
But the bulk of what happens every Friday is what comes next, kids throwing stones. It goes on for hours. It's become the Friday afternoon activity for a lot of kids and teenagers in Nabi Saleh. Teens sit with friends by the side of the road talking and rough housing and then occasionally picking up a stone throwing it or launching it with a slingshot. The soldiers, on their side, respond with tear gas, rubber coated metal bullets.
但每个周五发生的大部分事情是接下来发生的：孩子们投掷石块。这持续了好几个小时。这已经成为纳比萨利赫许多孩子和青少年的周五下午活动。青少年和朋友们坐在路边聊天、打闹，然后偶尔捡起一块石头投掷，或者用弹弓发射。士兵们在他们那边，用催泪瓦斯和橡胶涂层金属子弹回应。
[SHOT SOUND]
[枪声]
Two men have died from injuries they received at protests in Nabi Saleh in the last year and a half. But today, there's a lot of pretending to be fearless. One kid made a joke of acting like he'd been hit.
在过去的一年半里，有两人在纳比萨利赫的抗议活动中受伤死亡。但今天，很多人在装模作样地表现得无所畏惧。一个孩子开玩笑地假装自己被击中了。
[YELLS].
[尖叫声]
At this point, throwing stones is one of the most common charges against Palestinian kids who are arrested in the West Bank. There are Palestinians throwing stones just about every day, not only at protests and not only at soldiers. A few weeks ago, a Palestinian was convicted of throwing stones that killed an Israeli father and his baby when they were driving in the West Bank. A stone hit the father in the head, and he lost control of the car.
此时，投掷石块是被捕的巴勒斯坦儿童在西岸面临的最常见指控之一。巴勒斯坦人几乎每天都在投掷石块，不仅是在抗议活动中，也不仅是对着士兵。几周前，一名巴勒斯坦人因投掷石块造成一名以色列父亲及其婴儿在西岸开车时死亡而被定罪。一块石头击中了父亲的头部，他失去了对车辆的控制。
The army takes stone throwing seriously, whether the stones are being thrown at armored jeeps or unarmed civilians. Soldiers videotape the weekly protests. And in Nabi Saleh, the villagers told me the army does that so that it can take those images and compare them to the nighttime photos. That way, the army can arrest people who throw stones and go to demonstrations. It's safer and easier for the army to arrest people at night rather than at the demonstration itself, though arrests actually might not be the point of the nighttime photos.
军队非常重视投掷石块，无论石块是投向装甲吉普车还是手无寸铁的平民。士兵们会录制每周的抗议活动。在纳比萨利赫，村民们告诉我，军队这样做是为了将这些图像与夜间照片进行对比。这样，军队可以逮捕投掷石块和参加示威的人。对军队来说，在晚上逮捕人比在示威现场逮捕更安全、更容易，尽管逮捕可能并不是夜间拍照的重点。
My officer tells me-- he told me before we left, bring your camera.
我的军官告诉我——他在我们出发前告诉我，带上你的相机。
This is Nadav Bigelman. He was an Israeli soldier who took photos in mapping operations similar to ones in Nabi Saleh, He's 24 years old, and his army service ended in 2010. But his unit operated in villages that were also holding protests. Nadav said he'd just started his army service, and his commander told him to bring along his little Fujifilm camera one night to do some mapping.
这是纳达夫·比格尔曼。他曾是一名以色列士兵，在类似于纳比萨利赫的行动中进行过绘图拍摄。他今年24岁，2010年退役。但他的部队在进行抗议活动的村庄里活动。纳达夫说他刚开始服役，指挥官就在一天晚上让他带上他的富士小相机去进行一些绘图。
You know, it was like my first few duty line after basic training and all that. I thought I'd have, like, the most important intelligence material. Yes, I thought someone would come and ask for these pictures. I think, in my mind, this is the most logical thing to do, that someone, I don't know, intelligence, will ask for these pictures.
你知道，那是我基本训练结束后刚开始执行的几次任务。我想我会有最重要的情报资料。是的，我想会有人来要这些照片。在我的脑海里，这是最合乎逻辑的事情，会有人（不知道，可能是情报部门）来要这些照片。
But no one ever did ask for the pictures. Not only that, but Nadav says he later learned that all of the information they'd gathered, the ID numbers, the drawings of the layouts of the houses. all of it had gone in the trash. Nadav was a young soldier-- 19 years old. He didn't question why. He just deleted the photos.
但从来没有人要过这些照片。不仅如此，纳达夫说他后来了解到，他们收集的所有信息，身份证号、房屋布局图，全部都被扔进了垃圾桶。纳达夫当时是一名19岁的年轻士兵。他没有质疑为什么。他只是删除了这些照片。
Another soldier in Nadav's unit, Sagi Tal, confirmed that this happened. And Sagi said that over the course of his three-year army service, he saw the same thing happen again and again with mapping operations.
纳达夫部队里的另一名士兵萨吉·塔尔证实了这一点。萨吉说，在他三年的军旅生涯中，他一次又一次地看到绘图行动中发生了同样的事情。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
One of the ways that I came to understand that this was just an exercise in futility was that every time a new battalion would come in and be in charge of a certain area, they would order this mapping procedure all over again. And so it became clear to me that these photos weren't being used and didn't go into some kind of database the way we were lead to understand they would be.
我理解这是徒劳演习的方式之一是：每当一个新的营进来负责某个区域，他们就会再次下令进行这种绘图程序。所以很清楚，这些照片根本没被使用，也没有像我们被引导去相信的那样进入某种数据库。
In my unit, we called that kind of operations "Condoleezza Rice operations."
在我的部队里，我们将那种行动称为“赖斯行动”。
This is another soldier also named Nadav, Nadav Weiman. He was serving in 2008 when Condoleezza Rice was Secretary of State.
这是另一名也叫纳达夫的士兵，纳达夫·威曼。他在2008年服役，当时康多莉扎·赖斯是国务卿。
Because every time Condoleezza Rice came to Israel, we did that.
因为每次康多莉扎·赖斯来以色列，我们就做那个。
You did a mapping operation?
你们进行过绘图行动？
Yeah.
是的。
I thought Nadav Weiman might have had a different experience with mapping than other soldiers because he was in a special forces unit, and he was in charge of intelligence for his team, a sniper team. And he did have a different experience. The army sent him to a photo course and gave him a camera, a Nikon D200 with seven lenses. But when it came to mapping, it was the same with him as with other soldiers. He got back with all the photos and the information and the diagrams, went to his superior--
我以为纳达夫·威曼在绘图方面的经历可能与其他士兵不同，因为他在特种部队，负责小组的情报工作，是一个狙击小队。他的经历确实不同。军队送他参加了摄影课程，并给了他一台尼康D200相机，配有七个镜头。但当涉及到绘图时，他和普通士兵是一样的。他带着所有的照片、信息和图表回来，去找他的上级——
And I said, OK. There's all the maps and the photos and everything. And he said, Nadav, erase the photos and just throw the papers to the trash can. And don't ever come to me again with all the papers, because you don't need to do that.
我说，好的。这里有所有的地图、照片和所有东西。他说，纳达夫，把照片删了，把纸扔进垃圾桶。以后别再拿这些纸来找我了，因为你不需要做那个。
Were you surprised?
你感到惊讶吗？
Yeah, I was very surprised, because the first time we did that, we did it really seriously. You know, we asked, and we drew really accurate and everything. And then we understood that it doesn't really matter.
是的，我非常惊讶，因为第一次我们做的时候，我们真的很认真。你知道，我们询问，我们画得很准确等等。然后我们明白了，那其实不重要。
He says after the first time he did mapping, he just threw everything away automatically. I heard this, and I didn't understand. Why get all that information and photos and then throw it away? And why keep doing that over and over?
他说第一次绘图后，他就会自动把一切都扔掉。我听到这些，不明白。为什么收集所有的信息和照片然后扔掉？为什么要反复做这些？
I went back to Yehuda Shaul, the guy who first explained mapping to me and showed me the photo of the man in his pajamas. Again, Yehuda did his army service years ago during the Second Intifada. But he's been in touch with hundreds of soldiers since then, because after he finished his required army service, he and some others started an organization called Breaking The Silence that interviews Israeli soldiers about their experiences.
我回去找耶胡达·沙尔，那个最初向我解释绘图并给我看穿着睡衣男人照片的人。同样，耶胡达在几年前的第二次起义期间服兵役。但他从那以后与数百名士兵保持联系，因为在完成强制兵役后，他和一些其他人创立了一个名为“打破沉默”的组织，采访以色列士兵关于他们的经历。
Besides doing mapping himself, Yehuda's heard mapping stories from dozens of IDF soldiers-- Israel Defense Forces soldiers-- including ones who are serving now. And he wasn't surprised by what Sagi and Nadav and the other Nadav told me. He said it was the same for his unit in Hebron. They mapped the old city of Hebron twice, then destroyed all the data on the orders of their commander without ever passing it on or doing anything with it.
除了自己做过绘图，耶胡达还从几十名以色列国防军士兵（包括目前正在服役的士兵）那里听到了绘图故事。他对萨吉、纳达夫和另一个纳达夫告诉我的一切并不感到惊讶。他说他的部队在希伯伦也是一样。他们给希伯伦老城画了两次图，然后应指挥官的命令销毁了所有数据，从未传递给任何人或用它做任何事情。
Look, very quick you understand that mapping is just another form of making your presence felt, right?
听着，你很快就会明白，绘图只是让你感觉到他们存在的一种方式，对吧？
Making your presence felt. That's a phrase. It's a--
感觉到他们的存在。这是一个短语。这是一个——
Yeah. [FOREIGN LANGUAGE]. Demonstrating your presence. The idea is very simple. Every Palestinian feels that the IDF is always right here, you know?
是的。[外语]。展示你们的存在。想法很简单。每个巴勒斯坦人都觉得以色列国防军一直就在这里，你知道吗？
You're pointing right to the back of your head behind your left ear.
你指着你的后脑勺左耳后面。
Yeah, yeah. We're breathing behind you. We're always there. We're always watching.
是的，是的。我们在你身后呼吸。我们一直都在。我们一直在看着。
You never know where we're going to be, when we're going to show up, how it's going to look like, what we're going to do, when it's going to start, when it's going to end, right? So what do you do to make them feel this way? You make your presence felt.
你永远不知道我们会在哪里，什么时候出现，看起来是什么样，我们会做什么，什么时候开始，什么时候结束，对吧？所以你做什么让他们有这种感觉？你让人们感觉到你的存在。
But this is not a tactic. This is not a strategy that distinguishes between good guys and bad guys, right?
但这并不是一个区分好人和坏人的战术或策略，对吧？
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
[说外语]。
I spent an afternoon talking to seven boys who were photographed in Nabi Saleh, the village where I saw the weekly protest. Most had been photographed more than once. Some had later been arrested. Some hadn't.
我在纳比萨利赫度过了一个下午，与七个被拍照的男孩谈话，就是我看到每周抗议的那个村庄。大多数人被拍过不止一次。有些人后来被捕了。有些人没有。
One of the kids I talked to was the younger boy from Bilal Tamimi's video, his son, Muhammad. Muhammad was almost 12 when the soldiers took his picture. He's just turned 14. But he seems young for his age. He didn't act tough or indifferent when I asked him about soldiers taking his picture.
我和其中一个孩子谈过，他是比拉尔·塔米米视频里的那个较小的男孩，他的儿子穆罕默德。当士兵们拍他照片时，穆罕默德快12岁了。他刚满14岁。但他看起来比实际年龄小。当我问他关于士兵给他拍照的事时，他表现得并不强硬或冷漠。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
[说外语]。
I was surprised that they were there. This is the first time that they entered our house. I had thought about it a lot before but never expected it to happen.
我很惊讶他们在那里。这是他们第一次进入我们家。我以前想过很多次，但从没预料到会发生。
Muhammad's mother told me that he and his older brother worried in the weeks afterward that soldiers would come back. His older brother started sleeping in jeans and keeping his shoes next to the bed in case he was arrested in the middle of the night. Muhammad didn't like to sleep at all.
穆罕默德的母亲告诉我，他和他的哥哥在随后的几周里担心士兵会回来。他哥哥开始穿着牛仔裤睡觉，把鞋子放在床边，以防在半夜被捕。穆罕默德根本不喜欢睡觉。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
[说外语]。
I started staying up late, watching for the coming of the soldiers.
我开始熬夜，盯着士兵的到来。
His mother told me that for months she would wake up at 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning to the sound of the TV. And she would find Muhammad awake, half watching TV and half watching out the window to see if anyone was coming. Muhammad never was arrested, and neither was his older brother. But soldiers did come again to the house. Like before, it was around 1:30 in the morning.
他母亲告诉我，几个月来她会在凌晨4点或5点被电视的声音吵醒。她会发现穆罕默德醒着，半看电视半盯着窗外看有没有人来。穆罕默德从未被捕，他哥哥也没有。但士兵们确实又来了几次。和之前一样，大约是凌晨1点半。
And just like before, his father, Bilal, videotaped it. Bilal's had video cameras since he was a teenager. But a few years ago, he got a better one from an Israeli human rights organization called B'Tselem. Now he's got a video archive organized by date of the times the Israeli military has come into the village over the last couple of years.
就像之前一样，他的父亲比拉尔录了下来。比拉尔从青少年时期就一直有摄像机。但几年前，他从一个叫“B'Tselem”的以色列人权组织那里得到了一个更好的。现在他有一个按日期组织的视频档案，记录了过去几年里以色列军队进入村庄的次数。
Sit please.
请坐。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
[说外语]。
In this video, everyone has been woken up and is sitting in the kitchen. And one soldier is walking around with Bilal doing a search, asking him, in English this time, whether he has anything illegal or forbidden in the house.
在这段视频中，每个人都被叫醒，坐在厨房里。一名士兵带着比拉尔进行搜查，这次用英语问他家里是否有违法或违禁品。
Do you have something who is unforbidden?
你有非违禁的东西吗？
Unforbidden? Like what?
非违禁？像什么？
Yes. Like knives. Like weapons.
是的。像刀。像武器。
I have a lot of knives and the spoons in the kitchen.
我厨房里有很多刀和勺子。
The kitchen is OK--
厨房没问题——
In case you didn't hear it, Bilal is saying, I have a lot of knives and spoons in the kitchen. The soldier says, the kitchen is OK. I've got knives in my kitchen, too. The soldier keeps walking around with Bilal, questioning him.
如果你没听清，比拉尔说：我厨房里有很多刀和勺子。士兵说：厨房没问题。我厨房里也有刀。士兵继续带着比拉尔走来走去，盘问他。
Do you carry a weapon?
你携带武器吗？
Weapon? This is my weapon.
武器？这就是我的武器。
Bilal points to his camera as he says this.
比拉尔指着他的摄像机说。
OK. It's a good weapon.
好的。这是个好武器。
Yes.
是的。
Again, no one in the house is under arrest. The soldiers are just looking around, asking to see the older son's backpack, looking in cabinets and on shelves, asking more questions, and finally leaving. For sure, there are people in the West Bank who want to kill Israelis. Nadav Weiman, the special forces guy, showed me a photo he took after his team raided the house of a Palestinian man who had a workshop inside to build bombs.
同样，家里没有人被捕。士兵们只是四处看看，要求看大儿子的背包，翻看柜子和架子，问更多问题，最后离开。当然，西岸确实有人想杀死以色列人。特种部队的纳达夫·威曼给我看了一张照片，那是他的小队突袭了一个巴勒斯坦男子的房子后拍的，那个男人家里有一个制造炸弹的车间。
And we found a lot of ammunition and things inside his house and bombs and everything.
我们在他房子里发现了很多弹药、东西、炸弹等等。
Nadav says the raid on that house was based on intelligence. And Israel has an incredible amount of information about who and what are in the West Bank.
纳达夫说，对那所房子的突袭是基于情报的。以色列对于西岸有什么人、有什么东西掌握着惊人的信息。
They've got cameras, informants, listening devices, drones, undercover units. And Nadav says that over the course of his three-year army service, the conclusion he came to, based on his own experiences and conversations with other soldiers, including his two older brothers who are also special forces, was that some operations really were about gathering and using intel. He would go out and take reconnaissance photos, and they would be used.
他们有摄像头、线人、监听设备、无人机、卧底部队。纳达夫说，在他三年的服役过程中，基于他自己的经历以及与其他士兵（包括同样是特种部队的两个哥哥）的谈话，他得出的结论是，有些行动确实是为了收集和利用情报。他会出去拍摄侦察照片，这些照片会被使用。
But he says those operations, even for his elite team, were the exception. He believes that a lot of what they did, including most mapping operations, fell into a different category, the "demonstrating our presence" category. And in that category was a whole range of things from mapping to something else he says his team did called mock arrests. Other soldiers also talked about this. And a mock arrest is exactly what it sounds like, arresting someone who's not really under arrest. Even more than that, Nadav said before his team went out to do a mock arrest, they would call the Shabak, Israel's internal intelligence agency.
但他表示，即使对于他的精英小队来说，那些行动也是例外。他相信他们所做的很多事情，包括大多数绘图行动，都属于不同的类别：即“展示我们的存在”。在这个类别中，有一系列从绘图到他说的他们小队做的另一件事：模拟逮捕。其他士兵也谈到过这一点。模拟逮捕正如其名，逮捕一个并没有真正被逮捕的人。甚至不止于此，纳达夫说，在他的小队出去进行模拟逮捕之前，他们会打电话给以色列内部情报机构“辛贝特”。
And we'd say to them, we want to go to do mock arrest in that house. And we give the number of the house, because there's maps and all the houses are numbered. And they check.
我们会对他们说，我们要去那个房子做模拟逮捕。我们给出房子的编号，因为有地图，所有的房子都有编号。他们会核实。
And they have information about all of the Palestinians in West Bank. And they give us the OK, because if everybody in the house is innocent and not connected to terror, they say, OK, you can go.
他们有关于西岸所有巴勒斯坦人的信息。他们给我们绿灯，因为如果房子里的每个人都是无辜的，与恐怖活动无关，他们会说：好的，你们可以去。
Let me underscore what he's saying here. He said his team could only do a mock arrest after Israel's intelligence service told them that no one in the house is suspected of wrongdoing.
让我强调他在这里说的内容。他说他的小队只有在以色列情报机构告诉他们房子里没有人涉嫌违法后，才能进行模拟逮捕。
And we'd go in the middle of the night, and we surround the house. And we shout, come out with your hands in the air. And we throw stun grenades, or we fire bullets at the walls of the house. Or we throw smoke grenades.
我们会半夜进去，包围房子。我们大喊：举起手出来。我们投掷震撼弹，或者我们向房子墙壁开枪。或者我们投掷烟雾弹。
And then somebody comes out and is afraid, and he doesn't know what is happening. And we arrest him. And we shout a lot in Hebrew and Arabic. We arrest him. We put him inside a Jeep. And then we do like two or three rounds--
然后有人出来，他很害怕，他不知道发生了什么。我们逮捕他。我们用希伯来语和阿拉伯语大喊。我们逮捕他。我们把他放进一辆吉普车。然后我们转了两三圈——
Driving around the village.
在村子里开车。
Driving around the village. And then after, like, 20 minutes, 30 minutes, maybe the whole night, we put him back inside his house and drove away from there. And the goal in that operation, the goal is creating the feeling of being chased in the Palestinian population.
在村子里开车。然后大约20分钟、30分钟，也许整晚过后，我们把他送回房子里，开车离开那里。那种行动的目标，目标是在巴勒斯坦人口中制造一种被追捕的感觉。
To create the feeling of being chased in the Palestinian population was an explicit goal that Nadav says he saw many times typed out in the PowerPoint presentation his team would be shown before a mission, right there along with all the other official information.
在巴勒斯坦人口中制造一种被追捕的感觉，纳达夫说这是他在小队执行任务前展示的PPT演示文稿中多次看到的明确目标，就写在所有其他官方信息旁边。
Our team, our names, who is the officer, and what is the goal of the operation, and how we're going to do it, it's all written. And it's written to create the feeling of being chased in the Palestinian population just like that. That's the mission that I was sent. And you see that a lot of things I do in the West Bank as a soldier, I'm not here to protect Israel. I'm here to control Palestinians.
我们的小队、我们的名字、谁是军官、行动目标是什么、我们该怎么做，一切都写好了。上面写着要在巴勒斯坦人口中制造一种被追捕的感觉，就是这样。这就是我被派去执行的任务。你会看到我在西岸作为士兵所做的很多事情，我不是为了保护以色列。我在这里是为了控制巴勒斯坦人。
I ran all this by Lieutenant Colonel Peter Lerner, spokesman for the Israeli military, the Israel Defense Forces. I quoted to him the objective Nadav Weiman said he saw typed out before some missions.
我把这一切都告诉了以色列军队（以色列国防军）发言人彼得·勒纳中校。我引用了纳达夫·威曼说他在某些任务前看到的明确目标。
"To create the feeling of being chased in the Palestinian population."
“在巴勒斯坦人口中制造一种被追捕的感觉。”
I would not consider that a military objective at all. And when we do carry out military operations, a specific target would be to arrest an individual to gather intelligence for a specific mission. It would not be just to intimidate anybody. I would rule that out to begin with. Again, if there was a low-level commander making such a statement or event putting it in writing, it could be a mistake.
我根本不会认为那是一个军事目标。当我们执行军事行动时，具体目标是逮捕某个人，为特定任务收集情报。那绝对不是为了恐吓任何人。我首先就会排除这一点。同样，如果有一个低级指挥官发表了这样的言论，甚至把它写在书面上，那可能是一个错误。
I told Colonel Lerner about the mock arrests Nadav Weiman and other soldiers said they'd done. I asked him what's the purpose of a mock arrest.
我告诉勒纳上校纳达夫·威曼和其他士兵说他们执行过的模拟逮捕。我问他模拟逮捕的目的是什么。
I can't even comprehend that type of term. When we carry out an arrest, we carry it out. We take the person. We take them for questioning. It could be a short questioning.
我甚至无法理解那种术语。当我们执行逮捕时，我们就执行它。我们带走那个人。我们带他去审问。可能是短暂的审问。
You ask them a few questions. You see if there's any basis for further investigation. And he could be released. It wouldn't be a mock. I would say that that definitely not be how we operate.
你问他几个问题。看看有没有进一步调查的基础。然后他可能被释放。那不会是模拟的。我会说那绝对不是我们的运作方式。
You've never heard that term?
你从没听过这个术语？
No.
没有。
About mapping, he said--
关于绘图，他说——
In the past, we did military operations to map out populated areas to find out who's living where and who's doing what. I'm not aware of throwing data out or throwing intelligence out.
过去，我们进行过军事行动来绘制人口密集区域的地图，以查清谁住在哪里，谁在做什么。我不知道有什么销毁数据或销毁情报的情况。
Never. You've never heard of that?
从来没有。你从未听说过？
No. I doubt that would be the situation. It would defeat the object. We don't just send troops out just to go out. We safeguard our own safety. We don't send people and put them at risk. And we would look at every mission in a professional manner.
没有。我怀疑那会是那样的情况。那违背了目的。我们不会只是为了出去而派遣部队。我们保护我们自己的安全。我们不会派遣人员让他们置身险境。我们会以专业的态度对待每一次任务。
The years since the Second Intifada ended, around 2006, have been the quietest in a long time for Israelis, with some brutal exceptions. People don't worry about getting on buses the way they used to or try to find tables in cafes far away from the door in case a suicide bomber gets in. So you could argue that creating the feeling of being chased in the Palestinian population has worked, that mapping is important to Israel's security. And it doesn't matter whether data is kept or not.
第二次起义结束后的几年（大约2006年）是以色列人长期以来最平静的时期，当然也有一些残酷的例外。人们不像以前那样担心坐公共汽车，或者试图在远离门口的咖啡馆找座位以防自杀式炸弹袭击者进来。所以你可以说，在巴勒斯坦人口中制造一种被追捕的感觉奏效了，绘图对以色列的安全很重要。数据是否保留并不重要。
But mapping and mock arrests are just a small part of things in the West Bank. For the last few years, there's been this intense cooperation between Palestinian Authority security forces and Israeli security forces. And Israel's built a barrier, a series of fences and walls, in much of the West Bank.
但绘图和模拟逮捕只是西岸局势的一小部分。过去几年里，巴勒斯坦权力机构安全部队和以色列安全部队之间一直有这种密切的合作。以色列在西岸大部分地区建立了一道屏障，即一系列栅栏和墙。
Those things probably have a lot more impact on Israeli security than sporadic mapping operations. But then what's hard to calculate is the downside of mapping or mock arrests. What does it do when anyone, innocent or guilty, can be woken up by soldiers in the middle of the night along with their kids?
这些事情可能对以色列的安全产生的影响远大于零星的绘图行动。但难以计算的是绘图或模拟逮捕的负面影响。当任何人，无论是无辜还是有罪，都会在半夜和孩子们一起被士兵吵醒时，这会产生什么影响？
The soldiers who came to Bilal Tamimi's house and photographed his kids were notably polite. It's part of what makes the video compelling, the disconnect between how they're speaking and what they're doing. All of the soldiers I spoke with talked about feeling aversion of that disconnect.
来比拉尔·塔米米家给孩子拍照的士兵们非常礼貌。这正是使这段视频引人注目的部分原因：他们说话的方式和他们正在做的事情之间的脱节。我交谈过的所有士兵都谈到了感受到了这种脱节的某种变体。
And these are all people who entered the army wanting to protect their country. They joined combat units and did tough service. Nadav Weiman, the special forces soldier, wanted to be on the front lines. He went into Lebanon.
他们都是进入军队想要保护自己国家的人。他们加入了作战部队，执行了艰苦的勤务。特种部队士兵纳达夫·威曼想在前线。他去了黎巴嫩。
He was two days away from his reserve duty when we talked. And yet, he and the others I talked to feel that a lot of what they've done in the army is deliberate intimidation of civilians. They don't believe it made Israel safer in the long run.
我们交谈时，他距离预备役还有两天。然而，他和我都交谈过的其他人觉得他们在军队里所做的大部分事情都是对平民的蓄意恐吓。他们不相信长远来看这让以色列更安全。
And, yeah, these are a select group. A lot of people, inside the army and out, don't see it this way. Nadav Bigelman, the guy who had mapping photos on his camera, told me about one night when his unit was given glow sticks, like kids buy at concerts, before they went out on their patrol. And their commander said to throw them into people's houses. Just toss them through open windows or balconies.
而且，是的，这是一群精选的人。军队内外很多人并不这么看。纳达夫·比格尔曼，那个相机里有绘图照片的家伙，告诉我一天晚上他的部队被给了荧光棒（就像孩子们在音乐会上买的那种）去巡逻。指挥官让他们扔进人们的房子里。只需穿过打开的窗户或阳台扔进去。
And you can say, OK, it's not violent. It didn't harm anyone. But the idea is, again-- of course, just random houses, of course. The idea, again, is not the glow sticks but what the glow sticks make people think. I mean, just imagine, people wake up the next morning, prepare for school, to work, university, and they see a glow stick in the middle of their living room. And they understand the army was here.
你可以说：好的，这不是暴力。它没伤害任何人。但想法是，再次——当然，只是随机的房子，当然。再次强调，想法不是荧光棒，而是荧光棒让人们想到了什么。我是说，想象一下，人们第二天早上醒来，准备上学、上班、去大学，然后在客厅中间看到一个荧光棒。他们明白军队来过。
That's how 46 years go by, sometimes with a heavy hand, sometimes with a light touch.
这就是46年来的情况，有时用铁腕，有时用轻触。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our program.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "I TURN MY CAMERA ON" BY SPOON]
[音乐 - 勺子乐队的《I TURN MY CAMERA ON》]
Coming up, a kid's drawing in ballpoint pen on printer paper. What could that possibly be worth? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一张用圆珠笔画在打印纸上的儿童画。那可能值多少钱？一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program we're calling "Picture Show," about pictures and how the story that we tell ourselves about a picture totally determines what we see when we look at it. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, A Picture is Worth $1,000.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目我们称之为“图片秀”，关于图片以及我们对自己讲述的关于图片的故事，如何完全决定了我们看它时所看到的内容。我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕：一张图片价值1000美元。
Let's head now into the world of buying and selling pictures, where every picture has a price, the price is very, very high. This is the fine art world with collectors and galleries and, of course, artists. Scott Pinkmountain has this story about whether it is possible to get away from all that once you are deep inside it.
现在让我们进入买卖图片的世界，那里每张图片都有价格，而且价格非常非常高。这是纯艺术世界，有收藏家、画廊，当然还有艺术家。斯科特·平克山讲述了这个故事，关于一旦你深陷其中，是否有可能摆脱所有这一切。
Schandra Singh is a painter, a good one. Straight out of an MFA program, she landed a gallery in New York.
桑德拉·辛格是一位画家，一位优秀的画家。从艺术硕士课程毕业后，她在纽约就找到了一家画廊。
I was, like, minus $200 in my bank account. And I was driving to the city with some works on paper, because my dealer's like, well, maybe-- because I make really big paintings. And he was like, maybe if you have something small, we can sell it, you know?
我当时银行账户里是负200美元。我正开车去城里带一些纸上作品，因为我的经纪人说：也许——因为我做很大的画。他说：如果你有小一点的东西，我们也许能卖掉它，你知道吗？
So I'm driving there and I get a phone call from him, from my dealer. And he goes, Schandra. And I said, yes? And he goes, Saatchi just bought the "Lazy River" painting. And I just, like, dropped the phone and screamed.
所以我正开车过去，接到他，我的经纪人的电话。他说：桑德拉。我说：是的？他说：萨奇刚买了那幅《懒河》的画。我简直惊呆了，扔掉电话尖叫起来。
Saatchi would be Charles Saatchi, co founder of the international advertising firm Saatchi & Saatchi and owner of the Saatchi Gallery in London. He's ranked among the wealthiest people in the UK and probably the most closely watched contemporary art collector on the planet.
萨奇指的是查尔斯·萨奇，国际广告公司萨奇的联合创始人，伦敦萨奇画廊的老板。他名列英国最富有的人之列，也可能是全球最受关注的当代艺术收藏家。
He ended up buying three more from the show. Oh, and then when he buys it, what he does is that he automatically puts you on his website.
他最终又从展览中买了三幅。噢，而且当他买下它时，他所做的是自动把你放到他的网站上。
Which is a big deal in itself, because the Saatchi gallery website is hugely popular among collectors.
这本身就是一件大事，因为萨奇画廊网站在收藏家中非常受欢迎。
And then, I don't know, all these collectors come. And then I was offered a show right away with a really good gallery in Switzerland. My gallery in New York, again, automatically wanted to book my next show. Saatchi said he wanted to see everything that came out of my studio. Oh, my god.
然后，我不知道，所有这些收藏家都来了。然后我立即被邀请在瑞士一家非常好的画廊办展。我在纽约的画廊又自动想预定我的下一次展览。萨奇说他想看我工作室里出来的一切。我的天呐。
Soon, all the other paintings in her New York gallery shows sold out. Then collectors bought every single piece in her studio, completely cleaned her out. This pace continued for five years.
很快，她在纽约画廊展览中的所有其他画作都卖光了。然后收藏家买下了她工作室里的每一件作品，完全把她清空了。这种速度持续了五年。
This is a whole side of the art world that most of us only have a vague awareness of, where collectors buy and sell art like it's wheat futures or pork bellies. And Schandra's work was part of that. Schandra's gallery sold a couple paintings to this one guy who turned around and immediately tried to resell them for a big profit. It felt weird.
这是艺术界完全的一面，我们大多数人只有模糊的认知，收藏家像买卖小麦期货或猪肚一样买卖艺术品。桑德拉的作品就是其中的一部分。桑德拉的画廊把几幅画卖给了一个人，那个人转身立即试图以高额利润转售它们。感觉很奇怪。
And that's a lot of people do, particularly with Saatchi. Like, they buy what he buys. They don't even hang it in their apartment homes.
很多人都这样做，特别是萨奇的收藏。他们买他买的东西。他们甚至不把它挂在自己的公寓里。
They put it in a warehouse. And they watch the value go up or down. It's like stocks, you know? And then if it goes up, they hold onto it or they flip it.
他们把它放在仓库里。然后看着它的价值涨跌。这就像股票，你知道吗？然后如果它涨了，他们就持有它或转手卖掉。
You know, it's amazing to get all this success. But, like, painters really paint because there's sort of like this beautiful magic moment in it, you know? And after you're constantly making stuff all the time, and people are buying stuff, and then they're flipping paintings and it's all about money, it's like you just crave for that little magic moment again. It becomes corrupted if you let it.
你知道，获得所有这些成功令人惊叹。但是，画家真的画画是因为其中有一种像那种美丽的魔力时刻，你知道吗？当你不断地一直在做东西，人们在买东西，然后他们在转手画作，这一切都关于钱，你就渴望那种小小的魔力时刻。如果你允许它腐败，它就会腐败。
So it was in the midst of all this when something happened to Schandra. As she tells it, she was laying in bed struggling to get up and go to the studio to work on this big solo show.
所以，就在这一切之中，桑德拉发生了一件事。正如她讲述的那样，她躺在床上努力想起床去工作室为这个大型个展工作。
I look on my cell phone, and there's this email from this father in England. And he says that he's a really big fan of my work, and he has a 13-year-old autistic son who really loves my work, too. He's really moved by my work and that his son is an artist.
我看了手机，有这封来自英国一位父亲的电子邮件。他说他是我的作品的超级粉丝，他有一个13岁的自闭症儿子也非常喜欢我的作品。他被我的作品深深打动，而且他的儿子也是一名艺术家。
And he's making work all the time, and that he's currently doing a series called "Fire From the Eyes." And that he wanted to know if he could buy Anthony, his son, one of my drawings or something for him because it would just make Anthony so happy. And then he said, you can reach us at our email. And then he gave me his address. And then he wrote, you know, best wishes, Benjamin and Anthony.
他一直在创作作品，并且目前正在做一个系列叫“眼中的火”。他想知道是否可以帮他的儿子安东尼买我的一幅素描或者什么东西，因为那会让安东尼非常高兴。然后他说：你可以通过我们的电子邮件联系我们。然后他给了我地址。然后他写道：你知道，最美好的祝愿，本杰明和安东尼。
And when I got that, I was like, whoa, wow. There's this autistic boy in England who's moved by my work and really loves my work to the point that his father had to email me and tell me. And I just-- I don't know. It just, like, lifted me up.
当我收到那个时，我就想：哇，噢。英国有个自闭症男孩被我的作品打动，并非常爱我的作品，以至于他父亲不得不发邮件告诉我。我只是——我不知道。它只是，就像，鼓舞了我。
And so I just thought it was amazing. And I told the story to a lot of people. And I ended up writing back to him. And I just said, look, I'm honored that his son loves my work so much. And thank you so much for the email and that I'd love to see Anthony's "Fire From the Eyes" series.
所以我认为这太棒了。我把这个故事告诉了很多人。我最终回信给他。我说：看，我很荣幸你儿子如此热爱我的作品。非常感谢你的邮件，我很想看看安东尼的“眼中的火”系列。
And the next day, I get an email back from him saying, Anthony would love to send you some of his "Fire From the Eyes" series. And I'm thinking about this whole thing. And I'm telling people this story about there's this autistic boy who's going to be sending me his drawings.
第二天，我收到回信说：安东尼很乐意给你寄他的一些“眼中的火”系列。我正在思考整个这件事。我正在告诉人们这个故事，有一个自闭症男孩要给我寄他的素描。
And so I was like, why don't I just do a trade with him? It's just a sweet thing to do. If he's going to be sending me his art, I'll just send him something of mine.
所以我当时想：为什么我不直接和他做一个交换呢？这是一件甜蜜的事情。如果他要寄给我他的艺术品，我就寄给他一些我的东西。
So then he writes back, Anthony's so excited about the trade. He's like, he can't wait. And he's like, we sent your package.
所以他回信说：安东尼对交换感到非常兴奋。他说：他等不及了。他说：我们已经寄出你的包裹了。
So there's a lot of communication it sounds like.
听起来沟通很多。
Yeah, there was a lot of communication. And intimate communication, you know? He'd write things like, Anthony says hi. Anthony draws all the time.
是的，沟通很多。而且是亲密的沟通，你知道吗？他会写类似：安东尼向你问好。安东尼一直都在画画。
And so then this package arrives of these drawings. And they had written me a letter with it, from Anthony and Benjamin. And the drawings, I take the drawings out, and they're just, like, totally insane looking.
然后这个装有这些素描的包裹到了。他们随信写了一封信给我，来自安东尼和本杰明。我拿出素描，它们只是，就像，看起来完全疯狂。
They're just like, whoa. I mean, they're sort of stick figurey. But they're this man with his face with his mouth open. And then he's got all these googly things coming out of his eyes. And then there's random words written everywhere. And I was, like, transfixed.
它们只是像：哇。我是说，它们有点像火柴人。但它们是一个嘴巴张开的男人的脸。他眼里流出所有这些怪异的东西。还有到处写着的随机词语。我当时，就像，惊呆了。
All the pictures were nearly identical, drawn in ballpoint pen on pieces of plain white paper. Schandra wrote Benjamin.
所有的画几乎一模一样，是用圆珠笔画在普通白纸片上的。桑德拉写信给本杰明。
And I said, wow. These are so amazing. Thank you so much. I love his drawings.
我说：哇。这些太棒了。非常感谢。我爱他的素描。
A few days later, she received a second package of drawings.
几天后，她收到了第二个素描包裹。
And in that package were more letters and then a box of chocolates. And I was like, whoa, a box of chocolates, you know? And so then, I guess my drawing arrived.
那个包裹里有更多的信，还有一盒巧克力。我就想：哇，一盒巧克力，你知道吗？我想，我的素描应该到了。
And he said, Anthony's so excited. The drawing just came. He wants me to frame it for him. Thank you so much, Schandra. So glad to hear you got the box of chocolates.
他说：安东尼太兴奋了。素描刚到。他想让我为他装裱起来。非常感谢，桑德拉。很高兴听到你收到了那盒巧克力。
Did you eat the chocolate?
你吃那巧克力了吗？
I did. I did. It was good chocolate.
我吃了。我吃了。那是很好的巧克力。
Schandra's not a fool. She said there was a second before she bit into the chocolate where she wondered if she should eat it. Who were these people sending her chocolates and drawings?
桑德拉不是傻瓜。她说在咬下巧克力之前有一秒钟她怀疑是否应该吃。是谁在给她寄巧克力和素描？
She'd had little nagging doubts all along. And as things progressed, she wondered more and more about certain elements of the story. Like, how did Anthony find her work in the first place? Then Schandra was on the phone with a friend retelling the story in detail. Her friend was Nigerian, and he recognized Benjamin's last name as also being Nigerian.
她一直都有点挥之不去的疑虑。随着事情进展，她越来越怀疑故事的某些部分。比如，安东尼最初是怎么发现她的作品的？然后桑德拉在电话里和朋友详细重述了这个故事。她的朋友是尼日利亚人，他认出本杰明的姓氏也是尼日利亚的。
And he says to me, he's like, I don't want to make you feel bad or anything. He's like, but, you know, I don't really trust Nigerians. And this is coming from a Nigerian, right? And I'm like, what do you mean?
他对我说了，他：我不想让你感到不好什么的。但他：你知道，我其实不信任尼日利亚人。这是出自一个尼日利亚人之口，对吧？我说：你什么意思？
He's like, I don't know if I trust that this is real. And I remember feeling a little hurt by him even though I felt like I had no reason to be hurt by him. But I was, in my brain, like, what? You don't think I'm moving this autistic boy?
他说：我不知道我是否相信这是真的。我记得当时虽然觉得没有理由受到伤害，但还是感到有点受伤。但在我脑海里，我想：什么？你不认为我正在打动这个自闭症男孩吗？
And so I started asking people, like, do you think that this is real? And everyone I talked to would say, who would ever pretend to have an autistic child and then send you these drawings and write you these intimate details? Nobody thought it wasn't real.
所以我开始问别人：你认为这是真的吗？我谈过的每个人都会说：谁会假装有一个自闭症孩子，然后给你寄这些素描，并写下这些亲密的细节呢？没人认为这不是真的。
Schandra poked around online. She didn't really find anything. She never heard from Benjamin again, which felt a little strange, given how friendly and personal their emails had been. But she just let it drop.
桑德拉在网上搜索了一下。她没真正找到什么。她再也没收到本杰明的消息，这感觉有点奇怪，考虑到他们之间的邮件是多么友好和私人。但她只是放下了这件事。
Two years passed. Then, just a few months ago, Schandra was at a party in New York with a bunch of friends from grad school.
两年过去了。然后，就在几个月前，桑德拉在纽约参加一个聚会，和一群研究生院的朋友在一起。
And I was hanging out with a friend of mine whose work I really love and I think is a great guy or whatever.
我和我的一个朋友在一起，我非常喜欢他的作品，我觉得他是一个很棒的人什么的。
And we're talking. And he turns to me. And he says, oh, my god. I have to tell you. The most amazing thing just happened to me. And he goes on to tell me the same exact story.
我们正在交谈。他转过来对我说：噢，我的天。我必须告诉你。最令人惊奇的事情刚刚发生在我身上。他接着讲述了完全相同的故事。
Everything's the same, the dad in England, the autistic son, the names, the address, the wording of the letter, "Anthony really loves your work."
一切都一样，英国的父亲、自闭症儿子、名字、地址、信件的措辞，“安东尼真的很喜欢你的作品”。
And my first reaction was, oh, well, I guess he's just a fan of both of our work, and wasn't sure if we were talking about the same person.
我的第一反应是：噢，好吧，我想他只是我们俩作品的粉丝，我不确定我们是否在谈论同一个人。
This is Schandra's friend, a painter named Baker Overstreet. He's had a similar career arc to Schandra, both of them showing internationally, both collected by Saatchi right out of grad school.
这是桑德拉的朋友，一位名叫贝克·奥弗斯特里特的画家。他的职业生涯轨迹和桑德拉相似，两人都在国际上展出，两人都在研究生院毕业后就被萨奇收藏。
As I was describing it to her, I could tell she was eager to interject.
当我在向她描述时，我看得出来她很想插话。
And he's like, no, no. This couldn't have happened to you. And I remember I looked at him, and I was like, did you get a box of chocolates? And he just stared at me, like, with this funny face, right?
他说：不，不。这不可能发生在你身上。我记得我看着他，我说：你收到一盒巧克力了吗？他只是盯着我，就像，有一张有趣的脸，对吧？
Baker pulled out his phone and showed Schandra pictures he'd taken of Anthony's drawings. Schandra told Baker, those are the same drawings I got. They weren't photocopies or replicas, just very, very similar.
贝克拿出他的手机，展示了桑德拉他拍下的安东尼素描的照片。桑德拉告诉贝克：那些是我得到的相同的素描。它们不是复印件或复制品，只是非常、非常相似。
The moment that happened, it was like my confirmation. You know, I'd been skeptical before. But then I was like, this is a scam.
那一刻发生时，就像我的确认。你知道，我之前怀疑过。但当时我心想：这是一个骗局。
Because of Schandra's reaction, Baker decided to hold off sending a drawing. Schandra saw an obvious link. They'd both been collected by Charles Saatchi. Maybe Benjamin was just combing the Saatchi website looking for artists to write to. It makes sense. It would be an easy way to find artists whose work was potentially valuable.
因为桑德拉的反应，贝克决定推迟寄出素描。桑德拉看到了明显的联系。他们都被查尔斯·萨奇收藏过。也许本杰明只是在梳理萨奇网站，寻找艺术家来写信。这说得通。这是一个寻找可能价值不菲的艺术家作品的简便方法。
After I found out about this happening to someone else, I was like, this has to stop. This is wrong. And what this man is potentially doing, if it is the Saatchi website that he's getting the artists from, is that if he writes to, say, 500 artists, and only 100 artists respond with a drawing-- that drawing I gave him is valued somewhere between $1,000 and $2,000.
在我发现这件事发生在别人身上后，我就想：这必须停止。这是错的。如果他是从萨奇网站获得艺术家名单的话，如果他写信给，比如说，500位艺术家，只有100位艺术家回寄了素描——我给他的那幅素描价值在1000到2000美元之间。
The drawing that my friend would have given him might have been valued even higher, $4,000. He's got a $100,000 art collection. And getting the Saatchi artists to do it means that a majority of those drawings or those works are going to actually rise in price. So if he holds onto it for 30 years, he could have a $1 million art collection. It's, like, crazy.
我朋友本可能给他的素描可能价值更高，4000美元。他拥有一个10万美元的艺术收藏。而且让萨奇的艺术家这样做意味着这些素描或作品中的大多数实际上会涨价。所以如果他持有30年，他可能拥有一个100万美元的艺术收藏。这太疯狂了。
Was any of it true, Schandra wondered. Was there even an autistic boy out there who loved her work?
是否有任何一点是真的，桑德拉纳闷。甚至真的有一个热爱她作品的自闭症男孩在外面吗？
I don't know what to say. But it's just-- I mean, the way that this could actually be real, I feel like you'd have to find the people and say what's going on here? And I don't think talking, either, and I don't think writing letters, and I don't think writing emails is going to find out. I think actually physically meeting the boy. I don't know.
我不知道该说什么。但这只是——我是说，这种情况实际上可能是真的方式，我觉得你必须找到这些人，说：这里发生了什么？我不认为交谈，也不认为写信，也不认为写电子邮件能查出来。我想实际上亲自见那个男孩。我不知道。
So I suppose that would be A right there. Shall we?
所以我认为那就会是A了，对吧？我们要开始吗？
So feeling half like Geraldo Rivera and half like I'd just conned This American Life myself, I boarded a plane to London to either catch an international art thief or meet the loving father of an autistic teenage artist.
所以感觉一半像杰拉尔多·里维拉，一半像我自己骗了《美国生活》节目，我登上一架飞往伦敦的飞机，去抓捕一个国际艺术窃贼或会见一个爱心自闭症少年艺术家的父亲。
I thought requesting an interview over email or telephone would just give this guy a chance to turn me down. This American Life producer Jonathan Menjivar joined me there. And on a freezing cold Sunday afternoon, we went to the address that had been included in the letters to both Schandra and Baker.
我认为通过电子邮件或电话请求采访只会给这个家伙机会拒绝我。《美国生活》制片人乔纳森·门吉瓦尔和我一起去了那里。在一个寒冷的周日下午，我们去了寄给桑德拉和贝克信件中的地址。
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
Hi.
嗨。
I have to stop the tape right here. A woman answered the door, told us she didn't want to be recorded, asked us who we were and why we were there. She told us to go away.
我必须在这里停止录音。一个女人开了门，告诉我们她不想被录音，问我们是谁，为什么在那儿。她叫我们走开。
She said she smelled a rat. We left our phone number and figured Benjamin would never call us, that we'd flown all the way to London for nothing. And then, in less than two hours, we were stunned when he called and even more stunned when he agreed to let us come over.
她说她闻到了阴谋的味道。我们留下了电话号码，认为本杰明永远不会给我们打电话，认为我们白跑一趟伦敦了。然后，不到两小时，我们惊呆了，因为他打了电话，当我们同意让我们去他家时，我们更惊呆了。
I'm Scott.
我是斯科特。
Hi, Scott. This is--
嗨，斯科特。这是——
Hi. I'm Jonathan. It's nice to meet you.
嗨。我是乔纳森。很高兴见到你。
Is that recording?
是在录音吗？
It is recording.
正在录音。
Can you turn it off for us?
能为我们关掉吗？
Sure. Sure.
当然。当然。
Come on in. Come.
进来吧。进来。
Benjamin greeted us at the door to his home and let us in. He's a tall black man, about 40. He was in socks and a sweater. The place was modest.
本杰明在门口迎接我们并让我们进去。他是一个高个子黑人，大约40岁。他穿着袜子和毛衣。房间很简朴。
We entered the living room, and the woman who'd answered the door earlier, who turned out to be Benjamin's wife, was in one corner. A boy who was introduced to us as their younger son was on the couch playing a video game. There was no sign of Anthony. But I also didn't feel comfortable asking where he was right off the bat.
我们进入客厅，早先开门的那个女人（原来是本杰明的妻子）在角落里。一个被介绍给我们说是他们小儿子的男孩在沙发上玩游戏。没有安东尼的踪影。但我也不觉得舒服一上来就问他在哪。
We thought maybe the house would be packed with drawings and paintings by artists that Benjamin had written to. But there was no art on the walls. Instead, there were nails and hooks where things appeared to usually hang.
我们原以为房子里会塞满本杰明写信给的艺术家的素描和画作。但墙上没有艺术品。相反，墙上有钉子和钩子，看起来通常会挂东西。
Without any prompting, Benjamin explained they were in the middle of renovation, so they took everything down. There was tape around the edge of some of the windows, and the room smelled faintly of paint. We sat down, and Benjamin asked a lot of questions, what our motivation was, who this was for. Were we going to edit and manipulate the tape? Then he said OK, and then we started. I asked him to explain what's going on.
没有受到任何提示，本杰明解释说他们正在装修，所以他们把一切都取下了。窗户边缘有一些胶带，房间里隐约闻到油漆味。我们坐下来，本杰明问了很多问题：我们的动机是什么，这是给谁做的。我们会编辑和篡改录音吗？然后他说好，我们就开始了。我请他解释一下发生了什么。
Well, you know, from my perspective, Anthony is autistic. And he's got a gift, in my opinion, for art. Now, regarding contact with other artists, from my understanding, there's a tradition of artists exchanging works.
嗯，你知道，从我的角度来看，安东尼是自闭症。他有天赋，在我看来，艺术天赋。至于与其他艺术家的联系，据我理解，有一种艺术家交流作品的传统。
They exchange works left, right, and center. Internationally, there's this constant swapping of art, you know? So we're not doing anything different from what they're doing amongst themselves.
他们一直在交流作品。在国际上，有一种持续的艺术交换，你知道吗？所以我们做的与他们自己在做的事情没什么不同。
It's just that, probably, we're breaking into their circle in an unconventional manner. Now, who's this dude? He's written to that person and that person and that, but who is he? Is he real? Is he some fiction? Is he some big scam? And he's real.
只是，可能，我们是以非常规的方式进入了他们的圈子。现在，这个家伙是谁？他写信给那个人、那个人，但他是谁？他是真的吗？他是一些虚构吗？他是一些大骗局吗？他是真的。
Yeah, I mean what would you say to that? Is Anthony real?
是的，我是说你会对那个说什么？安东尼是真的吗？
Of course, Anthony's real. Yeah, he's real. Yeah, he's absolutely real.
当然，安东尼是真的。是的，他是真的。是的，他是绝对真实的。
Benjamin said, you'll get to see him. And we realized, oh, he's actually here in the house somewhere, though Benjamin didn't seem to be in a hurry to go get him. And before we had a chance to ask, Benjamin made it clear he wasn't going to let us speak to Anthony.
本杰明说：你会见到他的。我们意识到，噢，他实际上就在这房子里的某个地方，尽管本杰明似乎并不急着去把他带过来。在我们有机会询问之前，本杰明明确表示他不会让我们和安东尼说话。
We wouldn't be able to talk to him directly about these art trades. Benjamin later explained Anthony has trouble in social situations and especially with communication. He said it was best to speak on his son's behalf. We asked Benjamin how many artists he'd written to the way he'd written to Schandra and Baker. He wouldn't say.
我们将无法直接和他谈论这些艺术交换。本杰明后来解释说安东尼在社交场合有困难，特别是在沟通方面。他说最好代他的儿子说话。我们问本杰明他写信给多少艺术家，方式和写给桑德拉和贝克的一样。他没说。
How many artists have you contacted or communicated with about this?
你联系或交流过的艺术家有多少？
How many artists have spoken to you about it?
有多少艺术家和你谈论过它？
A couple.
几个。
Well, off the top of my head, I don't know. But let's just leave it at that.
嗯，我想不起来。但让我们就留在那儿吧。
I mean, I guess--
我是说，我想——
Specific numbers, I don't know specific numbers. Well, we'll put it this way. There have been quite a few. Put it that way. There have been quite a few. But to give you a number off the top of my head, no. But there have been quite a few.
具体数字，我不知道具体数字。嗯，我们换个说法。已经有不少了。就这么说吧。已经有不少了。但要让我直接给你一个数字，不。但已经有不少了。
Have quite a few responded by giving you drawings or paintings?
有不少人通过给你素描或画作来回应吗？
Well, I'm guessing if you guys flew in from New York, this is not just one or two drawings we're talking about. If you guys have come all the way from New York for this-- well, there's been quite a few. It's been quite a few. Put it that way.
嗯，我猜如果你们从纽约飞过来，我们谈论的不只是一两幅素描。如果你们为了这个从纽约大老远过来——嗯，已经有不少了。这已经不少了。就这么说吧。
Are we talking like 10 or 100 or--
我们是在谈论像10还是100或者——
Well, quite a few is what I will say.
嗯，有不少是我会说的。
We were annoying. We were persistent. At one point, Benjamin looked around the living room and answered at least a little more fully.
我们很烦人。我们很执着。有一次，本杰明环顾客厅，回答得稍微完整了一点。
If you take a look behind you, unfortunately, it was a blank wall. No, it's a blank wall. But you'll see there's some nails that we've put in. And it's because we've been painting.
如果你看看你身后，不幸的是，那是一面空白的墙。不，它是一面空白的墙。但你会看到有一些钉子是我们钉上去的。那是因为我们一直在刷漆。
And they're right up there, basically. Can you see? Can you acknowledge that you do see? You do see them. So, basically, we hang them up on the wall. I mean, over here, that's  one work. That's another work.
它们就在上面，基本上。你能看到吗？你能承认你确实看到了吗？你确实看到了它们。所以，基本上，我们把它们挂在墙上。我是说，在这儿，那是一件作品。那是另一件作品。
So we're looking at a blank wall here.
所以我们在这儿看一面空白的墙。
That's another work. It's a blank wall because we're painting. That's another work. That's another work. That's another one. That's another one. That's another one.
那是另一件作品。那是一面空白的墙，因为我们在刷漆。那是另一件作品。那是另一件作品。那是另一件。那是另一件。那是另一件。
There were maybe a dozen blank spots on the wall. Benjamin confirmed their collection was larger than that and added that they also change up what's hanging so the kids can appreciate different works. We asked for the names of the artists.
墙上可能有十几个空白处。本杰明证实了他们的收藏比那个还要多，并补充说他们也更换挂什么东西，这样孩子们可以欣赏不同的作品。我们询问艺术家的名字。
Benjamin either said he couldn't remember off the top of his head or he didn't want to violate their privacy. We asked to see Schandra's drawing. We wondered if he'd sold it. He went upstairs and was gone for a few minutes. Then he came back with the drawing. It was unframed.
本杰明要么说他想不起来，要么说他不想违反他们的隐私。我们要求看桑德拉的素描。我们纳闷他是否卖了。他上楼去了几分钟。然后他带着那幅素描回来了。它没有装框。
Yeah, so this is it. We're going to have it framed and put it up eventually.
是的，所以就是这个。我们最终会把它装框挂起来。
We asked lots of other questions. Why was Benjamin's correspondence with different artists almost word for word the same? He said, it's just a formality. Why vary it?
我们问了很多其他问题。为什么你和不同艺术家的信件几乎一字不差地一样？他说：这只是一个形式。为什么要改变它？
We asked, how did Anthony find out about Schandra's work? Benjamin explained that when Anthony finds artists, well, obviously, there's some adult input. He said, I can't recall where we came across her wonderful work.
我们问：安东尼是怎么发现桑德拉的作品的？本杰明解释说，当安东尼找到艺术家时，嗯，显然，会有一些成年人的投入。他说：我想不起来我们在哪里偶然发现了她精彩的作品。
Did you learn about Schandra and Baker's work from the Saatchi website? He said he found Schandra's work online but wouldn't get more specific. Did Anthony really have a special response to Schandra's work? How do you know what he responds to?
你是从萨奇网站上了解到桑德拉和贝克的作品的吗？他说他在网上找到了桑德拉的作品，但拒绝透露细节。安东尼真的对桑德拉的作品有特别的反应吗？你怎么知道他有什么反应？
Benjamin basically said a parent can just tell. Have you sold any of the work you've received? He replied that 99.99% of the collection is intact. After almost an hour of talking, my producer Jonathan cut in with this question.
本杰明基本上说父母一眼就能看出来。你卖掉过你收到的作品吗？他回答说99.9%的收藏品都在。交谈近一小时后，我的制片人乔纳森插话问了这个问题。
One of the possibilities, when you look at the situation, is that you're using his autism to collect art, that it is some version of a scam.
当你看这种情况时，可能性之一是你在利用他的自闭症来收藏艺术品，这是一种骗局。
That's interesting you say. I mean, yeah, you could say that. That's one way of looking at it, absolutely. I mean, it's not a scam. Put it that way. And I would understand if people thought that. But it isn't a scam. It's just a simple love of art, you know? That's all it is. Yeah.
这很有意思。我是说，是的，你可以那样说。那绝对是一种看待它的方式。我是说，这不是骗局。就这么说吧。如果人们那样认为，我也会理解。但它不是骗局。这只是对艺术的简单热爱，你知道吗？这就是全部。是的。
At one point, Benjamin was explaining to us what Anthony's early drawings were like. He told us Anthony was obsessed with trains. And then Anthony just wandered into the room.
有一次，本杰明正在向我们解释安东尼早期的素描是什么样的。他告诉我们安东尼迷上了火车。然后安东尼刚好走进房间。
--trains to begin with. That's Anthony by the way.
——最初迷上火车。顺便说一下，这是安东尼。
Here's one question we got a definitive answer to. Anthony is very real. He's a tall, broad shouldered teenager. He's 15 now.
我们得到了一个明确答案的问题是：安东尼是真实存在的。他是一个高大、肩膀宽阔的少年。他现在15岁。
He was barefoot, and I could see that a few of his toes and fingers were slightly malformed. He only kind of acknowledged us and went and sat beside his mother. I don't personally know much about autism, but Anthony appeared to have a disorder.
他是赤脚的，我能看到他的几个脚趾和手指有点畸形。他只是某种程度上承认了我们，然后走到他母亲身边坐下。我个人对自闭症了解不多，但安东尼看起来确实有某种障碍。
He spoke a few times but never to us directly. His speech was slow and hard to understand. Benjamin told us that their other son is also autistic. Benjamin mentioned that Anthony played piano. And when we finished our interview, they brought down Anthony's keyboard and set it on the table.
他说了几次话，但从没直接对我们说。他的说话很慢，很难理解。本杰明告诉我们，他们的另一个儿子也是自闭症。本杰明提到安东尼弹钢琴。当我们采访结束时，他们拿下了安东尼的键盘，放在桌子上。
I'm going to play rap.
我要弹说唱。
You want to play rap?
你想弹说唱？
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[播放音乐]
I'm a musician myself, and I've heard hundreds of piano improvisations. Anthony's music had the kind of spaciousness, repetition, and tiny deviations of some of my favorite avant-garde music. It was both thoughtful and intuitive, strangely confident and vulnerable at the same time. I was hearing something unique.
我自己就是音乐家，我听过数百次钢琴即兴演奏。安东尼的音乐具有我最喜爱的一些前卫音乐那种空间感、重复性和微小的偏差。它既体贴又直观，同时又奇怪地自信而脆弱。我听到了一些独特的东西。
I was really conflicted. I liked the family. They'd let us into their home and offered as tea and tolerated our questions. I believed that these were two parents who care deeply for their children.
我真的很矛盾。我喜欢这家人。他们让我们进了他们的家，为我们提供茶，并忍受了我们的问题。我相信这是两位深深关爱孩子的父母。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[播放音乐]
Wow, I'm going to clap for that.
哇，我要为那个鼓掌。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Bravo.
好极了。
What was that piece, Anthony? I couldn't tell it.
安东尼，那是哪首曲子？我听不出来。
I'm really [INAUDIBLE] Antipop Consortium.
我真的很[听不清] Antipop Consortium。
Oh, OK. Thank you.
噢，好的。谢谢你。
It's from [INAUDIBLE].
它来自[听不清]。
OK. I'm going to let him go.
好的。我要让他去休息了。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
Thank you very much.
When I got home, Benjamin finally gave me the names of a few artists who've collaborate with Anthony. I was able to reach three of them. They'd all gotten letters similar to Schandra's saying, I have an autistic son who's fallen in love with your art. Two of them got chocolates.
我回家后，本杰明最终给了我几个与安东尼合作过的艺术家的名字。我联系上了其中三个人。他们都收到了类似于桑德拉的那种信，说：我有一个爱上你艺术的自闭症儿子。其中两个人收到了巧克力。
The only artist I spoke to who actually met Benjamin and Anthony was Tillman Kaiser. They showed up at his gallery show in London last summer. He was also the only one who was able to address our biggest question, the thing we couldn't figure out at Benjamin's. Was Anthony truly engaged with the art his dad was exposing him to?
我交谈过的唯一一个真正见过本杰明和安东尼的艺术家是蒂尔曼·凯泽。去年夏天他们出现在他在伦敦的画廊展览上。他也是唯一一个能够解决我们最大问题的人（那个我们在本杰明家无法查明的事情）。安东尼真的投入了他父亲向他展示的艺术吗？
He was standing in front of the canvasses and sculptures and had a look. And I really had the impression that he enjoyed meeting me. And he seemed to be quite interested in the paintings and looked at them one by one.
他站在画布和雕塑前看了一看。我真的觉得他喜欢见到我。他看起来对画作很感兴趣，一幅接一幅地看。
Tillman said Anthony even made up his own titles for a couple paintings.
蒂尔曼说安东尼甚至为几幅画自己取了名字。
"Elephant Ears." And the other one, he called it "Drug Addiction." I mean, I think it's totally weired what they're doing. But I don't want to judge them, you know? I don't want to say they do bad things.
“大象耳朵”。另一幅，他称之为“药物成瘾”。我是说，我觉得他们做的事情太奇怪了。但我不想评判他们，你知道吗？我不想说他们做坏事。
Finally, I met again with Schandra and told her what I'd learned, that Anthony does exist, that he probably has some disorder, that Benjamin seems to be collecting from quite a few artists. She was torn.
最后，我再次见到桑德拉，告诉她我学到的东西：安东尼确实存在，他可能有一些障碍，本杰明似乎在从相当多的艺术家那里收藏。她感到很纠结。
It's like on the one hand, it's really wonderful. I wish maybe it would have been-- I guess, wish that maybe it would have been proposed to me that we have this autistic child, he really responds to art, we're amassing a collection of art for him to learn from, to be inspired from, to realize his own talents. It would be so special if we could do a trade with you, because we know he loves your work. Like, all these things maybe would have helped me kind of understand, as opposed to writing an email saying, you're the one that moves Anthony.
一方面，这真的很棒。我希望也许它会被——我猜，希望也许它会被提议给我：我们有一个自闭症孩子，他真的对艺术有反应，我们正在为他积累艺术收藏，让他从中学习，从中汲取灵感，让他实现自己的天赋。如果我们能和你做一个交换，那会很特别，因为我们知道他热爱你的作品。所有的这些事情也许会帮我理解，而不是写一封电子邮件说：你是打动安东尼的那个人。
And what if that's totally authentic?
如果那完全是真实的呢？
Well, I mean, I think it's a wonderful story then, that he's wanting to do all of this for his children. But it's just like, why did Baker and I feel so awkward when we found out that we both got asked the same thing? Why did we both think it was so much about us, you know?
嗯，我是说，那是一个精彩的故事，他想为他的孩子们做所有这些。但这只是——为什么贝克和我在发现我们俩都被要求做同样的事情时都感到那么尴尬？为什么我们俩都觉得那很多是关于我们，你知道吗？
So yes, Schandra thinks Benjamin could be more transparent with the artists he's contacting. But I agree, if he's doing this for his kids, that's a wonderful story. It's optimistic. And so many artists are optimists.
所以，是的，桑德拉认为本杰明可以在他联系艺术家时更透明一点。但我同意，如果他是为了孩子做这件事，那是一个精彩的故事。它是乐观的。而且很多艺术家都是乐观主义者。
Proof? Schandra's friend Baker, hearing what we discovered in London, still wants to send Anthony a drawing. Two of the other artists I'd spoke to, artists who'd sent Anthony their work, were totally OK with what Benjamin's doing.
证据？桑德拉的朋友贝克听到我们在伦敦的发现，仍然想给安东尼寄一幅素描。我交谈过的其他两位艺术家（寄给安东尼作品的艺术家）完全同意本杰明所做的事情。
And if there's one thing I've learned from this experience it's that, man, artists are an easy mark, because it's so obvious what they want. They want to reach people. Otherwise, why show your art? Why be an artist?
如果我从这次经历中学到了一点，那就是：天哪，艺术家是容易上钩的人，因为他们想要什么太明显了。他们想接触人们。否则，为什么要展示你的艺术？为什么要成为一名艺术家？
So all you have to say is, I'm moved by what you do, or my kid is moved by what you do. So many artists are like, you want to pay me? Great.
所以你要说的就是：我被你的所作所为打动了，或者我的孩子被你的所作所为打动了。很多艺术家会这样：你想付钱给我？太棒了。
But you say you love my work? Even better. Let me send you some.
但你说你喜欢我的作品？更好。让我寄一些给你。
Scott Pinkmountain is a composer and musician and writer in Pioneer Town, California. By the way, you can see some of Anthony's artwork at our website.
斯科特·平克山是加利福尼亚先锋镇的作曲家、音乐家和作家。顺便说一下，你可以在我们的网站上看到安东尼的一些艺术品。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "LET ME MOVE YOU" BY JIMI HENDRIX]
[播放音乐 - 吉米·亨德里克斯的《LET ME MOVE YOU》]
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and me with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Phia Bennin.
今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩和我制作，参与者有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·科尼格、三木·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自菲亚·本宁。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our administrative assistant. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes.
塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格德斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ对我节目的管理监督来自我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生。
You know, I have asked him so many times over the years, over and over. And every time I get the same answer. I ask him, Torey, how many women have you slept with?
你知道，多年来我问过他很多次，一遍又一遍。每次我都得到同样的答案。我问他：托里，你和多少个女人睡过觉？
Quite a few, of course. Put it that way. There's been quite a few. But, you know, to give you a number off the top of my head, no. But there have been quite a few.
当然，不少。就这么说吧。已经有不少了。但，你知道，要让我直接给你一个数字，不。但已经有不少了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC PLAYING -"LET ME MOVE YOU" BY JIMI HENDRIX]
[播放音乐 - 吉米·亨德里克斯的《LET ME MOVE YOU》]
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。